- Doin' what you love to do.
Doin' what you love to do
is the way that you're going
to give the best to the world!
And for me my brand is
about the live performance.
It's about touring.
It's about, you know, comin' out here
and hostin' these parties and havin' fun
touchin' the people.
Once you make this stuff,
put yourself out there
so people can hear it!
- He's an American recording
artist and record producer
from Washington D.C.
He's produced hit singles for
a number of prominent artists
in a variety of genres.
He's also the founder
and CEO of SuperPhone,
and NextSelection Lifestyle Group.
He's Ryan Leslie, and
here is my take on his
Top 10 Rules For Success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite!
Also as Ryan is talking if
he's says something that's
really meaningful to
you, please leave it in
the comments below, and
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(dramatic music)
- At 15 years old, you went to Harvard,
scored 1600 on the SAT, graduated--
- Did your research!
- Graduated at 19, and at 19 when you
gave the commencement speech
at Harvard, you said that
you wanted to be a performer,
and some people laughed.
Tell me about that.
- Well I mean you just
have to think, you know,
after four years and $120,000
worth of, you know....
arguably one of the greatest
educations that the world
has to offer, at Harvard.
There's so many other opportunities
and pathways that you
could take as a young,
bright, and even an African American,
you know, there's like, you
know, there's already so many
African Americans that want
to rap, or that, you know,
they want to make music.
Why can't we have an incredible outlier?
Why can't we have someone
who's, you know, an incredible
spokesperson like other--
- But we can!
- Another Barrack Obama
so to speak, you know?
And for me, it always
once again comes back to
what we touched on before which is,
doing what you love to do.
Doing what you love to do is the way
that you're going to give
the best to the world!
And I knew that anything else
that I did, whether it was
takin' a job or boss of
consulting group or, you know
even the community service
and philanthropy initiatives
in which I was involved.
You know I have a
passion for those things,
but none of them even remotely touches
the passion that I have for
live performance and music.
Number two, hard work.
'Cause guess what?
The life that I live, goin'
from country to country,
stage to stage, shootin'
music videos in the studio,
it seemed like everywhere
I go people ask me,
"Ryan, how can I get that life?"
The only way I was able to
get it was by working harder
than everyone else who said
they wanted it, but didn't
work hard enough to get it.
My words of advice are really
the same words that I spoke on
when I was a teenager, and
I needed money for college.
And so I head to the speech competition
for Rotary International and...
the topic that they asked me
to speak on, was...
"Do what you believe in and
believe in what you do".
And even now 12 years
later, when I look around,
that's what I strive to do
everyday, do what I believe in
and believe in what I do.
For everyone out there that has
an aspiration, do something!
Don't let anyone tell you
what you can and cannot do!
If you got a dream and a
goal and a passion to do it,
you know, I can't tell
you the amount of people
that told me,
"Look Ryan, stick to stand
behind the synthesizer or,
if you go and sing, don't
try to rap, or if you rap,
don't try to sing, or if you produce,
don't try to be an artist,
if you're an R&B dude,
don't try to go into the
rock or alternative side,
or if you don't dance, don't try to dance,
or if you dance, don't,
you know, don't decide it
you just going to stay
behind the keyboard."
Really for me, I think
artistry, the beauty and the joy
of artistry and the beauty
and the joy of just havin'
the freedoms that we enjoy in
life, is that we can pursue
anything that we want to pursue
and with the right mix of
drive, desire, discipline, and dedication
we can achieve anything that
we want to achieve and so for
all you all out there that have
a dream, I encourage you to
keep striving, pushing
forward toward that dream,
and make it happen, man!
There's a lot of rap artists,
or hip hop artist, you know,
or urban music artists that go
overseas and they just assume
that, you know, it's a
privilege for that market to
have them there and they
don't really deliver on the,
in terms of a live experience,
you know, they come over,
they might give a half an
hour show, 40 minute show,
they do it to track, they go out there,
they collect the money 'cause
it's good money out there,
and they come home and
because their touring base
is in the States, they
leave a lot of fans,
really disappointed, you know?
And it's been my strategy to
go out there and really just
shatter anyone else's
live performance, at least
at the level that I'm doin' it right now,
we doin' 1,200 to 2,000 seaters, you know,
maybe 3,000 in some markets,
and really just shatter
everyone's expectations
about what egotism, you know,
an American artist might
have by comin' out there,
and we've built an incredible
tourin' base, you know.
Honestly if you average
it out, we doin' probably
$1.2 million a month in Europe, you know,
if we go out there for a month.
So, that's 40,000 tickets
at 35 Euros a ticket
top-line, you know, you do the math.
- [Interviewer] I also read
that this new project you
plan to release each song with a video?
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] For free?
- [Interviewer] So why do
take this major bet like you
giving music?
- Well I mean, really, if
you look at the economics
of the music business right
now, you're really making money
when you're on the road,
and when you're touring.
And so, it's like...
Have you ever paid to download
a Coca-Cola commercial?
No.
Have you ever paid to download
a commercial for a car?
No.
So, all the money that they spend
in creating an advertisement
for just a can of Coke
or Pepsi, I mean, the Superbowl
just happened in the United States.
All of the big advertisements,
the amount of money that
they spend to create
those advertisements, you're
watchin' them for free.
And what it really is is a
call to action for you to
buy into the brand, and for
me, my brand is about the
live performance, it's
about touring, it's about,
you know, comin' out here
and hostin' these parties
and havin' fun touchin' the people.
And so, when people are
paying that, you just really
have to think, when someone
pays $20 to come to the club,
that's double the price of
an album, you know, and they
might do that three of four
times a year, as opposed to
buying your album one time for 10 dollars.
So I'm lookin' at this
as an advertisement for,
Ryan Leslie the brand, Ryan
Leslie just the personality
'cause I like to come out, you know,
(speaks French)
I want to be able to touch the
people, and I want people to
have a reason to want to
come and interact with me.
Yeah, so I look at it that way.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so you
plan the future to no more
rely on the album or CDs or...
- I would say there's very
few artists that actually
even make money from record sales, right?
Because the record labels
have given them an advance
and they only make money
when they do shows,
or they do appearances, or
they sell t-shirts, you know?
We go the "NS For Life"
hoodies, man, you look at my man
right there you get the "NS
For Life" hoodie, you know?
It's something that you can't
download, that experience
you can't download, and
I'm not stupid, man.
I know what's goin' on, I
mean, you know, when you
look at the streaming
services, when you look at the
file sharing services, people
are going to share your stuff
anyways digital, you know,
whether it's a photograph,
or a song so the concert experience...
that's something that you
can't download, you know?
Either you have a ticket
to the Jay-Z concert,
or you just at home, you know what I mean?
You can't download that experience.
So, my interest in making an
album with all the visuals
and all the music, is to create a demand
for that concert experience
that you can't download.
- So you're not strictly an artist?
You're a businessman!
- Yeah!
- What could you really say in terms of
handling your business in an
economy like this that people
really have to focus on these days?
Cause I think very few
people who are watching
this right now could really say, you know,
I'm good for 10 years, financially.
Most people are living
paycheck to paycheck,
month to month, they may have a little bit
of savings but they're not sitting on
a decade's worth of living expenses.
- You know it also depends on what you're
living expenses are, you
know, I live within my means.
You know what I mean? So--
- So that's the first thing.
The first thing is that you
got to live within your means.
- Yeah, you know, so, if
you decide that, you know,
and I have friends that
decide they want to be
in the penthouse before
they can afford to really be
in the penthouse but they can
afford to be in the penthouse
for a year maybe, so they
go and do that for a year.
And, I mean, to each their
own, everybody has the
prerogative to live
however they want to live.
So, we're not promised tomorrow,
so there are a lot of people
who just have the idea,
"Hey, let me live for today!"
You know what I'm sayin'?
- Fault to a fault.
- Yeah, you know what I'm sayin'?
So, it's all good!
I mean, for me it's just about
just bein' responsible and
cognizant of what you
need to be happy, yeah?
And so, for me, all I need is,
the ability to keep creating,
and uh, I'm good.
- The first time I met
you, you told me that,
this is when you were a
producer for Bad Boy, and
you told me that Tommy Mottola
and Puff used to always
tell you, "Why do you
want to be an artist?
You're hustling backwards!"
What did they mean by that,
and why did you persist to
continue to become an artist?
- Well I think they really,
being the luminaries
that they are, and the moguls
that they are, you know
they were talking much
more in terms of just
the generation of income,
and for me, generating income
in a way that, you know,
is just left of center
of what you love to do
is not the way I want to live, you know?
And I feel like the American
dream, which is, you know,
what I really consider
myself the embodiment of,
I feel like the American
dream is bein' able to
make a living doin' what you love to do.
And so for me, production was
always just a stepping
stone to amass enough money
so that eventually as the
music industry shifted,
I could buy my contract out,
and reinvest all the money that
I had earned into doing what
I really love to do which is
bein' on stage playin', and you know just
goin' runnin' around the world
and playin' shows for screamin' audiences
all over the world.
When you want to get your music out...
people usually think it two
ways, radio and television.
In 2010, there's a new way,
it's called the Internet.
(assembly laughs)
Right?
Youtube!
So once you make your stuff,
once you make your stuff,
put yourself out there
so people can hear it!
And if enough people respond,
I'll give you three examples,
Soulja Boy.
- [Audience Member] Justin Bieber!
- Justin Bieber.
(assembly laughs)
And also,
And also, the guy who you
see standing right here.
Right?
If someone's a true fan they
will actually, you know,
they'll let you know what
their opinion is but,
at the end of the day, it's entertainment.
So, if they don't want to listen
to what I'm talkin' about,
there's plenty of other
people out, I mean,
just go search Youtube, R&B
singers, and you can go find
a whole bunch of R&B singers,
but if you like what I do,
which is, just being
as honest as I can be,
and you know, makin' the
records from scratch,
I mean, that's really,
that's really where I have
biggest fan base, right?
It's from the Youtube
videos of me in the studio.
So nothin' about that has
changed at all, I mean,
I'm still in the studio makin'
the songs from scratch and,
you know, I have a different
perspective, I have a different
life experience that I'm writing from.
I'm going to say an affirmation,
and at the end of the affirmation
I will ask, "Who am I?"
And you will respond, "I'm
a Harlem Jet!" Who am I?
- [Audience] Harlem Jet!
- [Ryan] That's right!
Now I understand that obstacles
are really opportunities,
to learn, and to grow
stronger! So when I am met with
the challenge, I will rise
to the occasion, and I will
do my best to set an
example of perseverance,
of persistence, and of
discipline, for my community.
Who am I?
- [Audience] A Harlem Jet!
- [Ryan] That's right!
Now I might not have all
the money in the world,
but I do understand I have
the same 24 hours in a day
as anyone else.
And so in the interest of becoming great,
I have no problem making
the commitment to invest
more of my time,
in becoming the best representation
of myself that I can be.
Who am I?
- [Audience] Harlem Jet!
- Now I understand that
whether I'm on the field,
or off the field, the same
principles of love, teamwork,
fairness, and collaboration.
I understand that those principles apply
in my everyday life, and I
will do the best that I can to
treat other with the
same respect with which I
want to be treated, and do the same
for our environment as well.
Who am I?
- [Audience] A Harlem Jet!
- Now I understand that no
matter where I am today,
no matter the struggles
that I'm going through,
or that my family is going through,
no matter what my world looks like today,
the world that I will live in tomorrow,
will be the world that I create,
and I will never allow anyone to keep me
from pursuing my dreams.
I love life, I love my family,
I love my community,
and I love my country.
Who am I?
- [Audience] A Harlem Jet!
- [Ryan] Who am I?
- Who am I?
- [Audience] A Harlem Jet!
- Who am I?!
- [Audience] A Harlem Jet!!!
- God bless you all, God bless Harlem,
and God bless the USA, I'm Ryan Leslie.
(audience cheers)
(inspirational music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I made this video because
Perle Pons asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what
did Ryan say that left
the biggest mark on you, what
change are you going to make now
after watching this video?
Leave it down in the comments.
By writin' it, you'll solidify
your intent to actually
follow through on it,
and hopefully inspire
other people as well so
leave it in the comments,
I will join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout-out to
Paulette from totallyinspiredmind.com.
Paulette bought 10 copies of my book,
thank you so much it
really, really, really
means a lot to me!
Thanks again for watching,
I believe in you!
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon!